>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> David Plylar: Good
evening everybody.
My name is David Plylar
and I'm a music specialist
at the Library of Congress.
It's really great to see you here
tonight for our next installment
in our exploration
of the collaboration
of the Isamu Noguci
and Martha Graham.
Two 20th century masters
whose work continuos
to resonate far beyond the
confines of their own life times
and many artistic arenas.
We are very pleased tonight to
be able to present Dakin Hart,
senior curator at Noguchi Museum.
And the title of his talk,
as you can see on the screen,
is Sculpting Beyond the Pedestal:
Isamu Noguchi's Sets for Dance.
As part of our Martha Graham
at library festival week,
we've been very fortunate and being
able to present these very close
up looks at the relationship
between Graham and Noguchi.
Last night, we heard the perspective
of the Graham artistic director
Janet Eilber, a dancer who performed
with Noguchi's breath taking
mythic set design for many years.
Tonight, we hear the curatorial
perspective from someone
who oversees the Noguchi Museum's
exhibitions and collections,
archives and public programming.
You'll see a nice line and
Dakin Hart's bio in our program
that he has the daily good
fortune to collaborate
with Isamu Noguchi in absentia.
Before joining the
Noguchi Museum staff,
Dakin worked as an independent
curator and writer and served
as an assistant director of
the Nasher Sculpture Center,
artistic director at Montalvo
Center for the Arts, and later,
assistant to the director of the
Fine Arts Museums of San Francisco.
It's been very rewarding
to collaborate
with him specially my colleague Anne
McLean worked very closely with him
in developing this
miniseries focusing on Noguchi.
And both he and his colleague
Janine Biunno were very generous
to the library with their
time and with their ideas.
Without them, we would
not have been able
to reproduce the beautiful
images that you've see
around of Isamu Noguchi's work.
And we've able to share
throughout the festival.
We would also like to acknowledge at
this time again the generous support
of Dr. Sachiko Kuno and
Ryuji Ueno in helping
to make these events possible.
So, without any further ado,
please welcome Dakin Hart.
[ Applause ]
>> Dakin Hart: Thank
you so much David.
It's an honor to be here.
I'm very excited to be here
talking about Noguchi and Graham.
It was, obviously, a really
important relationship in his life
and it's one of those things I
was just saying to a new friend.
That I didn't expect that when
I went in the Noguchi Museum
that I would end up
having a relationship
with the Martha Graham
Dance Company.
But, it's been wonderful.
And Janet and I did talk
together just a couple a weeks ago
in the studio at Westbeth
in New York.
And they put out three of the
sets, did an open rehearsal.
And we are able to go-- and the
entire audience who's able to go in
and amongst the sets, walk
on the sets, lay on the sets,
play with the sets, touch the sets,
and that's the great
privilege for me, too.
I deal with these sets
everyday or bits
and pieces of these sets everyday.
But in the museum, we
threat them as artwork.
So, when I touch them,
I touch them with gloves
and I try not to touch
them very much.
So, having the chance to get
up there and actually jump
under Costa's [assumed
spelling] bed is a great thrill.
And these sets really don't come
to life until they're in the midst
to Martha's choreography.
That was the reason for being.
So, we try not show them isolated.
We tried to always show them in
the context of the choreography
because they're really
are only an artwork kind
of consolidated all as a whole.
So, tonight, we're going to try to
answer a question which is really
to try to explain how Noguchi ended
up where he ended up 80 years on
but do it through the lens of
dance because dance arguably is one
of the two or three things that
really went in to the Booyah Base
of his especial brain and
makeup that allowed him
to be truly avant-garde and really
shift the terms of sculpture.
So, what we're looking
at are two images.
This is Noguchi as a teenager.
He-- You may or may not
know, apprentice for a time
to Gutzon Borglum who
made Mount Rushmore,
who was a terrible
human being, who--
a racist and just really
awful person.
And told Noguchi at 18 that he would
never a sculpture to give it up,
forget it about it and
go back to med school.
And Noguchi listened to him very
briefly and-- but in the end what,
you know, sort of the bread and the
bone allowed and Noguchi, obviously,
did not listened, ultimately.
And so we're looking at him making
for a public audience a copy
of Borglum's sculpture of Lincoln.
And this was a very, very quick
kind of proof of his virtuosity.
At this point, he'd only been
sculpting for really a few months.
And he just had that special
thing that Raphael called Disegno,
which is the connection between
eye, hand, and imagination.
He just had it.
And on the right, we're looking
at a bust of George Gershwin.
So, Noguchi for about 10 years
really was a academics sculpture.
This is, again, in
his early to mid-'20s.
And he made a living by doing
what he called head busting.
And that meant making portrait
heads of well-known people,
bold face names in New York City.
And it was also a way to try to
get commissions for real sculpture.
He hated doing it by
the way, but he did.
So, how he ended up here, on the
left we have Beinecke Library.
This is the Sunken Garden Project,
working with an architected
that he collaborated
with over and over again.
It's an amazing project.
It is-- He referred to these
as gardens even though it looks
like an enclosed courtyard and
it is an enclosed courtyard.
Very conceptual in white marble,
contains really symbolic
elements representing the sun,
the earth and chants.
And on the right, we have a Black
Slide Mantra which is working slide.
It happens to weigh 80,000 pounds
and be made of black granite.
And it took so several
years to make.
But it is a working slide.
And that's where he really
ended up in his heart.
Now, the other sort of great--
late in life work that I want to
mention just way of setting things
up here is the museum itself, which
a lot of people think of as one
of his greatest artworks.
And we try to not monkey
around with it too much
because it really is
a total work of art.
And here, we're looking at
a section of the garden.
OK. So, Ruth Page is a wonderful
dancer and choreographer,
who's a perfect contemporary
of Martha Graham's.
But is not very well-known,
because she's from Midwest.
And she really made her career in
Chicago, in and around Chicago,
although she was an
international traveler.
She performed at Hirohito's
investiture as emperor in Japan.
She was the only western
artist to perform there.
She performed shortly after the
revolution in Russia, took the train
to Moscow and performed there.
She really was an amazing person.
And Noguchi worked with her
before he did with Martha Graham,
sort of a little known
Noguchi story.
And he fell madly in love with her
at an arts clubs at
Chicago performance.
He was there with an exhibition and
he-- she was seating behind him.
And they just hit it off right away.
What we're looking at here
is a kind of chicken and egg
that we haven't been
able to resolve.
On the right is a sculpture
called "Miss Expanding Universe".
And on the left is Ruth Page
in Sack Dress that Noguchi made
for her, made with his own hands.
You can see it encloses
her feet and her hands
and it's nipping of the ways.
And there's a clear physical
relationship between that
and the sculpture on the right.
The piece that's hanging
from the ceiling
on the right is cast aluminum and he
is holding the plaster model for it.
And what you can see is a
very proprietary sort of way.
What's important about
this, as you can see
that in the sculpture he's turn her
into a constellation and has tried
to set her among the stars.
And this idea of expanding universe
comes from a series of lectures
and then ultimately a book that
Sir Arthur Eddington wrote,
published in 1932,
the exact same year.
And Noguchi likely saw
a lecture in Cambridge,
Massachusetts with Bucky Fuller.
And this lecture was called
the "Expanding Universe".
The book he published is called
And basically, for a
sophisticated lay-audience,
what he did was explained the
ramifications of Einstein's theory
that energy and matter were more
or less the same thing
at different speeds.
And that, space and time
are basically can warp.
And what's extra ordinary about this
and Ruth is in away demonstrating.
On the left, she's just playing.
It's a wonderful image and you got
to see some of her sense of humor.
But, on the right, we're seeing a
still essentially from the dance
that she made that was called
the "Expanding Universe"
where she performed
all over the country.
It debuted in Grand Rapids, Iowa.
And she sent him-- a little town.
She sent him a telegram, Noguchi
a telegram the next day saying
that she worried-- she was concerned
that she had seriously
upset the town's people.
That there were some indications
that it maybe hadn't
gone over all that well.
But that she felt very good
about their quote unquote "baby."
And that she was going
to keep working
on it and keep performing it.
Here she is on the stage and she
took it among other dances to Japan
on tour and with a wonderful
modernist dancer, German modernist.
And what one thing that we know
we know it from a gossip column
in Chicago actually, but
it's the only details we have
about the rest of the stage.
There was a scrim at the back of the
stage which they had poked holes in
and then there were
lights behind the scrim.
So it was meant to
look like a starry sky.
So she's performing against a starry
sky, incredibly simple concept,
incredibly probably
very rough execution,
but it must have been pretty poetic
with her essentially becoming a kind
of amorphist cloud, you know, sort
of galaxy dancing around on stage,
which brings me to sort of
specifying this long digression.
This is Ptolemaic Universe which
being kind of lived with for
about 1500 years before
the Copernican revolution.
And what you can see,
what's meaningful about it
in this context is how tidy it is.
For a long time we imagine that
the universe was this incredibly
Euclidian world of
concentric circles
with us at the center of course.
The earth is at the center here.
And what the Einsteinian
revolution really did was
to really dramatize the fact
that not only was the universe
not centered around humanity,
but that it was not in any
way shape or form tidy.
And this is kind of a better look
at what an Einsteinian
universe might look like.
You know, it's a big blob that's
expanding very, very quickly.
If you think about it, this is one
of those mental shifts that's
not unlike the French revolution.
You know, kind of a moment
in-- or the moon landing,
a moment in mankind's understanding
of itself when it totally shifts.
They're not only are we not
at the center of the universe
but the universe is not a clean
and tidy mathematical place.
Well it is mathematical,
but the rules that it follows are
incomprehensible to most of us.
This is all hugely
important backdrop.
I mean, it will surprise
you that I'm saying that.
But Noguchi, this is what
was in Noguchi's mind
when he was working with Ruth Page.
So-- And the third wheel in the
relation ship was Bucky Fuller.
So they are seriously trying to
understand what it means to live
in this new Einsteinian universe.
And he is trying to capture
that and it is changing the way
that he thinks about space.
It's changing the way he
thinks about what kind
of sculpture he wants to make.
He doesn't want to make tidy
Ptolemaic, Euclidian sculpture.
He wants to make untidy, crazy,
truthful to nature
Einsteinian sculpture.
Now, the way that sort of relates
to Graham and Ruth particularly
because it would be a couple
of years before he would work
with Graham for the first time.
Here, she is on the left and she
is performing in a tube dress,
wool jersey, and she's performing
Lamentation, which is from 1930.
Have any of you seen Lamentation?
It is in-- still in [inaudible].
It's wonderful dance.
The company last year did a kick
starter campaign to raise money
to get five young choreographers
to create Lamentation variations,
which were by enlarge really
terrific, really interesting.
So the Lamentation is as most Graham
things are an inward turning dance,
you know, tightly coiled.
Graham like to say, you know, she
always would talk about the hands
and when in doubt make a first.
You know, turn the hands
inward not outwards.
Noguchi was an outward
spreading kind of guy.
His first real self-portrait is a
sculpture I'm not showing called
"Glad Day" which a
William Blake takeoff
of just a spready gold
figure kind of ready
to take off into the firmament.
And you can see that's what
Ruth is doing here on the right.
So it's a pretty start contrast.
But it's a really useful
one to understand
because that's what he brought
into his relationship with Martha.
Now they've known each other a long
time before they worked together.
They probably got to know each
other in 27, 28 right around there.
They were part of the same circles.
They're going to the same cafes.
They both were sort of
enamored Sandy Calder.
They both helped to perform
Calrder's Circus which was kind
of wonderful, if any of you
have seen it at the Whitney.
It used to be a kind of traveling,
movable feast of performance.
And a lot of artist participated in
it because it was fun and, again,
expanding the notion of sculpture.
So when they finally-- well, so just
kind of quick, quick interlude here.
Noguchi in between
before the Martha--
first Martha project did
exactly what expanding universe,
kind of suggested which is to
try to break out of the mold
and do something different
in the sculpture.
So this is one of a couple
of projects that he developed
and then proposed in
his wonderful way
to the Works Project Administration.
So he was brought on
board as one of the artist
to the Works Project Administration.
This is the beginning
of the depression.
And the problem was that they didn't
believe that this was sculpture
and they didn't believe
that is was built.
I think they thought that he
was having them on actually.
And they kick-- They
actually kicked him out.
They revoked his status as a Works
Project Administration artist.
This is called "Play Mountain" and
it's meant to be one city block.
And he proposed it and in full
seriousness he presented this
to Robert Moses as well who had
already taken over at the Department
of Parks in New York City on his
long ascent through the ranks there.
And he laughed him out of
the room basically and said--
I think what Noguchi said
exactly was, "I earned nothing
that day but his undying enmity."
And that proved to be the case
because Noguchi would spent 40
years trying to make a playground
in New York City and never succeed.
We'll talk a little bit
more about that later.
This is a wonderful thing, you could
see it's sort of Mayan step pyramid.
It has water feature which
is down at the bottom
and a huge diving board, it
could also be drained and used
as a concert area performance space.
And then you could see at the
top there's a long looping ramp.
So that was meant to be a kind--
it's an all weather play mountain
because that was meant to be
sliding hill in the winter.
And you can see if they
built this thing somewhere
in New York City we'd still be
pleased, but it was never realized.
Although kind of a
version was posthumously
in a park outside Sapporo in Japan.
This is the other one
of those projects.
This is called "Monument
to the Plow".
And this was meant to be more than--
about 1200 feet on a side
at the base and the idea was
that it would be in crop rotation.
So the four sides of the pyramid
would be planted and through
out the year and done in such
a ways to make it sustainable.
And the face of each one was meant
to be sort of 40 acres in the plow.
So plowable by one person
in a day with a steel plow.
And the whole idea was
that it was celebrating.
So his great mentor Edward Rumely
who was an American industrialist
the kind great [inaudible] sort had
told him that Ben Franklin
and Thomas Jefferson had invented
the steel plow between them
and that they believe that it was
the thing the tool that was going
to settle, quote unquote,
settle the American West.
They didn't invent the steel plow
John Deere invented the steel plow.
But they popularized it hugely.
And so, this-- you-- it's
a little bit hard to see.
But at the very tippy top of
this pyramid there's a cap--
a smaller concrete pyramid which
is toped by a big rippling ribbon
of stainless steel,
though it was meant
to be an abstract celebration
of the plow.
Noguchi's thinking a lot about--
Noguchi went to high school in
Indiana, Rolling Prairie, Indiana.
He was meant to go to a
school called Interlaken,
not the music school, but another
one that Edward Rumely had founded
which was the premise
of the school was
to create great American
industrialist by having boys--
it was all boys, learn
to do in a hands on way.
So they built the whole
school by hand.
And they did internships with local
factories and the whole idea was
to have managers and then
eventually owners of companies
who really knew how to do
things with their hands.
And then Noguchi took that to
heart he was a very physically
intelligent person.
That's one of the things that
he and Martha shared so closely.
You know we tend to underrate
all forms of intelligence other
than the linguistic kind.
You know, we sort of overrate
linguistic intelligent,
but there are a lot of other kinds
and physical intelligence
is one of them.
And he and Martha Graham
are about physical geniuses.
This is the thing that
he designed from scratch.
You may have heard of but
there's a little clock case
and there's the radio and
there's the baby monitor
and that Noguchi made in the '30s.
And that both those cases he just
design the case for mechanisms
that somebody else had made.
In this case, this is
really his invention.
This is called musical weathervane.
And basically the idea is that it is
a weathervane that's internally lit
with a bulb and it has slots in it.
You can see it looks little
bit like the side of a shark.
Those are really gills and wind
would blow through from the front
and then pass through
the gills and make music.
What kind of music?
I'm not sure.
Probably would bit of that pleasant.
But his thought was that it would
end up on if everything went right,
the roof of every barn
in the Midwest.
That was his hope.
And he really was working
to the heart land.
That is where his heart was at.
It's where his brain was at.
And, you know, I think
it's projects like this
that really prepared
him to work with Martha.
And the sort of the mystery why
they didn't work together earlier,
he did propose a project, probably
around 1928 to her and Leon Theremin
who invented the Theremin, you know,
the first electronic
music device basically.
We have him to blame
for the synthesizer.
Not-- He's not really to blame.
But the Theremin rod is a rod that
would emit sound when touched,
you know, has a field,
electric field around it.
And just by touching or getting
close to it you affect the field.
And Noguchi's idea was to plant an
entire field of these rods on stage
and then have Martha dance through
them and the idea would be that she
and Theremin who also
written music, very good music
that they would write the
choreography and the score together
so that the score and the
choreography would be identical.
So that as she dance, she would
produce the score as well as--
I mean it's such an amazing idea.
That's where Noguchi's
mind was and both she
and Theremin probably just look at
and like he was nuts and said no.
So it didn't happen.
But I think she probably
thought he just wasn't ready.
He was significantly younger.
He's half a generation
younger than she was.
And she was much further ahead and
they were both after the same thing,
which is to really change
their respective media
in a meaningful was.
But she-- again, she was
just sort of more developed.
So, she maybe just
been waiting for him
to catch up with her, and he did.
So, we'll just take a quick
look here at Frontier.
So here is the entirety
of the set for Frontier.
This is 1935.
Martha, you know, was famous for not
having sets and not needing sets.
That was one of the
contributions that she was making,
which was to divorce dance
from all the froufrou
and to make something really
stripped down and clean and direct.
And so it took her awhile to come
back around to integrating sets
in someway into the work.
And it's kind of wonderful
that this is such an early one
and she really couldn't pick
anybody better than Noguchi to do it
because what they shared in common
was this interest in abstracting
in order to universalize.
And they both had a really
great bed of knowledge
by this point for doing that.
And so she had proposed to him that
he do railroad ties receding away
from the audience towards
a vanishing point
at the back of the stage.
And the worse way to get Noguchi
to do something was to suggest it.
So, he dismissed that out of hand.
But it gave-- you know, she was
really brilliant and I encourage any
of you, if you haven't, to go on
the Library of Congress' website
in database, because they have
so many documents available.
And they're available by PDF, in
large JPEG, and you can get clips,
but also original programs.
You know, for long time
Martha didn't write program,
which was really frustrating
for those people trying
to understand what she was
doing, but she did write letters
to her collaborators telling
them what she was after
and she's a wonderful writer and
wrote at great length and a lot
of that is available on the
Library of Congress' website.
So anyway, we have-- that's why we
have a sense of what she was after
and what Noguchi came
up with instead.
So, we have a rail split, split rail
pose fence and with single piece
of rope that's knifing up off
stage in either direction.
So, you know, I think it's
worth trying to figure
out what he was trying
to deliver for her
and it's an idea not unlike what we
find in Albert Bierstadt, you know,
he's trying to capture something,
obviously, they both were
about this idea of the American
West, manifest destiny, you know,
there's a wonderful theory that was
really had qualified by this point,
but not that much before
this called the Turner Thesis
or the Frontier Thesis.
Total-- Really worth reading about.
But his basic theory was that the
American people developed indirect
response, or the kind of
the American way our base--
our core DNA developed
indirect response
to confrontation with the Frontier.
And so perpetually as we move
west continuing to be in dialog
with this idea of a Frontier and
that it's what's really responsible
for the development of democracy
that it's really what's responsible
for development of egalitarianism
and pluralism and all of the values
that we like best about
our democracy.
Really interesting thinker that's
still a really important tenant
of a lot of teaching of the
Frontier and the American West.
So this is the basic idea that she
proposed, as he said railroad ties.
So, it's just worth looking
sculpturally for a second
at the way he flip this notion.
First of all, he didn't want it
to be purely terrestrial, right?
What the rope does is that it
doesn't just add into the distance,
which it does, because it's
still has a vanishing point,
but that vanishing point
is an anchor, right?
It ties it to a specific
place on the earth.
That's one thing that Noguchi
is just sculpturally speaking is
really, really good at.
It's very difficult skill, but
it's one that he excel that,
which is to combine specificity
and abstraction just the right
quantities and just the right way.
You know, there's always--
in his abstractions,
there's always enough what I call
metal Velcro for you to connect to,
but there's nothing so specific
that you get bored because as soon
as you kind of answer it, you
know, you get tired of it.
So there's nothing really
to get too specific about,
but he did give her an
anchor point on the planet.
But he wanted to the vanishing
point or the lines to becoming
from outer space, to becoming from
off planet and I think that's--
it's a lovely twist on her idea,
because it does something
to the idea of Frontier.
And what so genius about Martha,
of course, and characterizes--
I'm just to skip ahead
of here for a second.
This characterizes their
collaboration from beginning
to end is that she took it, she
run with it, she made it better,
she built the kind
of the whole concept
of the dance around it in the end.
If you look at that thousand
yard stair she has going, right?
She's looking off into eternity.
And she is-- she--
people do talk about this,
but it's easy to get lost what a
brilliant characterizer she was.
She was really a wonderful actress.
And then, she could convey
so much with so little
and that's what she's
doing here standing
in front of this fence, right.
She's sort of a figure head, right.
She is on the prow of America.
It's such-- just a
beautiful simple image.
And particularly the way she set
herself against the fans, you know,
so that she is a vertical
post at the center.
I sort of skip over some
other wonderful imagery here.
Here, she's making herself the
fence, becoming one with the fans,
but she's able to do because,
you know, she's obviously famous
for her leg lifts,
unbelievably strong and able
to go truly parallel here on
one foot, pretty stunning.
So she's really mimicking
in a way this parallelism.
So, we're going to jump
ahead a little bit.
That was their first work together
and it would be their only work
together for about 10 years.
Noguchi was doing other thing.
She was doing other
things, the depression.
There was a lot going on.
Noguchi was actually
doing pretty well.
And he did not lower
his sights, did--
his ambition only mounted
over this period.
So, what we're looking at here
is the Ford-Chassis Fountain.
This is a fountain that he made
for Ford Motor Company's pavilion
and the World's Fair,
3940 World's Fair.
And, it's a very peculiar thing.
At the top of this post with--
I think I maybe able to--
that didn't work-- is a Ford V8.
So, it's celebrating-- this fountain
celebrates the Ford Drivetrain.
It's such a crazy idea.
So, vaulted up into
the air at the tip
of the fountain is an engine block
and then there's a crankshaft
that runs down to the base.
And then parallel to it-- yes, so
you can see a tire down at the base
and it's on a strut and it has--
it's in a wheel well and
this is a working fountain.
So, water came shooting up over
the tire and hit the crankshaft
and then spun down
around the crankshaft
into the basin of the fountain.
This is 22 feet tall and it stood at
the center of the Road of Tomorrow,
which was like one mile long track,
amazing thing where you could go
and test the latest Ford
Lincoln cars driving
around Noguchi's fountain.
Made out of magnesite, which
is a totally unstable material
that was a competitor for
awhile of Portland cement.
But it failed because
it's not chemically stable
so it eats itself alive.
We have a number of
pieces made of this stuff.
Noguchi never met a new
material he didn't like.
He always tried new things,
new tools, new technologies.
He's a technology geek.
Anyway, so that's what
he's thinking.
This is a nine ton stainless
steel panel he made and a kind
of socialist realist mode.
It's still there.
This is Rockafeller Center.
It was on the Associated
Press building and you can see
that it's celebrating
the four freedoms sort
of before they were fully enumerated
but this is really
celebrating the press
as the protector of our freedoms.
It's an amazing thing.
It was the biggest stainless steel
panel ever made and Noguchi insisted
on grinding it most of it
himself into the dismay
of the unionized labor force at
the metal works where it was cast.
He also was hard at work
on playground ideas.
And so this is all equipment,
these are models of equipment
that he designed at the request
of a parks director in Honolulu
who was prepared to do this
and then very sadly died
and didn't get a chance
to realize it.
One in a long string
of disappointment
for Noguchi on the playground front.
Coming out of that, he
came back to New York
and designed what he
called contour playground.
This was a response to
the Parks Department
because they criticized his play
equipment for being too sharp
and maybe being dangerous.
They were really just trying
to give him a hard time.
So he made a perfectly swoopy
playground called contour playground
with no right angles, no hard edges.
And the concept was that this
would fit somewhere seamlessly
into Central Park and that
it would be indistinguishable
from the surrounding landscape.
And the beautiful idea that
Noguchi enumerated was that he said,
he wanted people and he
was just starting to think
of as an environment maker at
this point that he wanted people
to experience his environments
as man first experience the earth
with kind of the sense of
discovery in this awe and sense
of the sublimity of it all.
Here's another.
Look at it and you can see how
actual playground equipment would be
integrated into the park.
Robert Moses laughed this
one out of the building, too.
Now, we come back to-- back
around-- we're mid-war here now.
And the set for this is just
next door, which is so amazing.
And they're going to be
performing on it in the place
where it was originally performed.
And what's so fantastic, so
Martha Graham has just had a bunch
of new sets made because they
go through them pretty fast
because they-- there's a lot of wear
and tear from moving these things
around and then actually
performing on them.
You walk on them, jump on them.
The dancers are big beefy, the
men, especially, big beefy people.
It's amazing that they
survive as long as they do.
So here we are looking at
the first installation.
This is not a model.
This is actually the
set as it was installed
in the auditorium next door.
And you can compare this
with how it looks now.
It is, had-- you can see that they
did a lot to cover up all of the--
well, actually the decoration is
very similar to what's in here.
So it's got a lot of molding
and wind [phonetic] skidding
and they covered it all up.
That's all Noguchi.
So that's probably cut fabric and
the kind of wavy bits at the top.
And I was just talking with Janet.
They had to on the roof frame
the kind of a long member
of the roof frame that
goes off stage to the left.
They had to cut that in half and
put a joint in it just a couple
of days ago to get it in there.
Because all of the molding and the
wind skidding is right in the way.
And this stage is about a
quarter of the size of the stages
that Martha Graham usually works on.
You know, it's incredibly
compressed and compact.
But you can see Noguchi
and Martha both coming back
around to this Frontier America
idea and developing it further.
And she gave him incredibly
explicit requirements.
We have another fence.
She wanted the inside and
the outside of a house.
She explained things like
with the racking chair
which has become quite famous,
that Noguchi made out of plywood.
She said that she wanted
the bones of a chair
or the skeleton of a chair.
And what she liked about Noguchi
was what she called his astringency
that he kind of cut everything away
like acid that he boiled it down.
And you can see that's
exactly what he did here.
And this is the first
of a long series
of pieces I'm really
fascinated by Noguchi's rocks.
So you can see the black kind
of ovoid with lines on it.
That's just for purchase.
So that when the preacher
figure jumps up on
to it he doesn't go
sliding right off again.
But that is a rock which rock by
way of being a soapbox, right.
This is his perch where he gets up.
And it's nice to think
about those connections.
You know, they're-- they
both are very youngin.
They're both thinking
about Greek mythology.
They're both always
rooted in the ancient past.
That's another thing they
really share in common.
And Noguchi is thinking about
the fact that in any community,
probably in the history
of the world,
the first soapbox is
always a rock, you know,
before there's anything else there.
That's what you get out on
top of if you want to declaim.
So, we're just going to go
through and look at some
of these great 40 sets in order
to just really quickly touch
on these cultural values.
I'm sure Janet was great
on program last night.
So I'm going to kind of stick
more to values as cultural values.
This is Herodiade set which
is a take off on the Salome.
These are both-- they're all--
in this period, they're all pretty
much biblical or mythological,
the basis for the dances
and Martha again brilliantly
developing program.
The funny thing is, although Noguchi
was also very talented in this area,
Martha usually did that
with the composers.
And Noguchi would often come
into these projects pretty late.
I think she just partially knew
that she could leave it till late
and that, once things were developed
enough he would give her just what
she needed to kind of take it off
in another direction
in just the right way.
And I think she used him in order
to kind of cut through the program.
Because again, she would develop
and it would be so sophisticated,
there were so much of
it, so much language.
That I think she got to a point
where she needed to break away
from all of that and Noguchi
did that with his sets.
You know, he made it super
simple, super elemental.
And once she had all
that research binder,
it was just what she needed
again kind of to shoot her
out on the right trajectory.
So what we're really looking
out here is a bedroom set.
And the piece on the left
is a mirror, hard to believe
but it comes right out of the
sculpture that Noguchi was making
and exactly the same time,
the interlocking sculptures.
But it's a mirror in the form of a
kind of skeletal Herod, you know,
truly terrifying idea that
Salome would look into the mirror
and what she would she is this kind
of hulking skeletal figure of Herod.
And the way Martha
explained the program--
again, she tended to abstract
and abstract and abstract
and by the time she got to writing
in her program what she was doing
by this point, you get like
two sentences that are really,
really vague, brilliantly vague.
So at the center we have a stool
and on the right hand
side we have a close rack.
And so, it's really
again, it's a good war set
but it's just a pretty
threatening good war set.
Because, of course, the coat rack
looks like something that, you know,
Peter was crucified on
and the stools really
not all that comfortable.
But it's an environment
for self reflection.
You know, that's really what it is.
It's an interior, sort of--
this is inside Salome
or a person like Salome.
Martha explained it
as her as the waiter.
That she's somebody who's
waiting and waiting and sort
of terrible circumstances with
her attendant and trying to figure
out what's going to happen to her.
And this is sort of-- well, the
mirror in particular is the--
that sort of the specter of what
is going to happen or might happen.
And the-- what it's so meaningful
for Noguchi or what's so important
for Noguchi because of
course, here this is--
again, going back to
the Parks Department.
To many people this is not
sculpture, was not sculpture,
but Noguchi despised the
balkanization of creativity.
You know, he thought the idea
that he was a different person
when he designed a table
versus when he made a piece
of sculpture was idiotic.
It just didn't make any sense.
So I don't turn off half of my soul.
I'm the same person
and I approach it
with the same level of seriousness.
So here our contemporaneous
piece of sculpture
and a contemporaneous
actual piece of furniture.
The Herman Miller coffee table on
the right, which is a lot of people,
maybe the most famous coffee
table of the 20th century.
And on the left, his largest
of the interlocking sculptures
which is a piece that's
on permit view
at the Metropolitan Museum of Art.
It's a Kouros.
It's nine feet tall.
But it's totally disassemblable,
packs flat.
The table packs flat,
too, by the way.
Major Noguchi value,
flat packability.
He thought like an industrial
designer whether he was making
sculpture or lanterns
or anything else.
He thought-- And he thought in
terms of flat materials and how
to take flat material stock
which was cheap and easy to move
for him alone and then turn it in
to something three dimensional.
And those values just happen to
coincide perfectly with set design
because that's what you
want in a set as well.
So we're going to spend just
a second on Cave of the Heart.
This is a really great set
for understanding a lot
about the way Noguchi's three
dimensional imagination worked.
I apologize for the quality of this.
This is a still.
It's very hard to find photographs.
We don't actually have one in our
archives of the entire set together.
It's always sections of it.
So this is the set
for Cave of the Heart.
On the left, you see a
number of just small pieces
down the floor, those
are the islands.
And then at the center is a piece
that he referred to as aorta.
And then on the right,
two pieces together,
the spider dress and the serpent.
And those are connected but then
they get this connected at one point
because the spider dress is a
garment that Martha would put
on in her role as a kind of Medea
figure, an avenging angel motivated
by rage and revenge and really fury.
But what's going on here that's so
neat and where Noguchi really locked
in is if you look at the islands,
they're the smallest
thing on the stage.
And when the-- this male
figure you can see is sort
of a stride the islands right now.
He makes them look very small and
you get the sense of uberous, right?
The sort of over-winning
pride and this idea
of clauses [phonetic] striding
across the islands of Greece,
owning the islands of Greece,
dominating the islands of Greece.
He's playing really great
games here with scale.
And that is the most important
thing that a sculpture does, can do.
It's the most important tool
in a sculpture's toolbox is
an understanding of scale.
And it's set against a
model of the human heart.
And the idea of Cave of the Heart,
of course, is that we're journeying
into the dark deep
recesses of the human heart.
In this case sort of at its
worst because, you know,
Medea is a horrible avenging figure.
She kills her own children
to punish her husband, Jason.
Jason is the wonderer, the seeker.
He's the figure who's
striding the islands.
So this picture of him stomping
all over Greece is also a sort
of her projecting, right?
It's-- you can imagine her.
If you're going to write her
in contemporary dialogue today
which she would accuse Jason
of, you know, it's easy to come
up with dialogue and sort of, again,
him as his over-winning
prideful jerk, essentially,
which of course he was because he
dumped her for a younger princess.
Now, she was the granddaughter
of Helios.
So you don't really want to mess
with the granddaughter
of Helios, the son.
And that's why Noguchi made
for her this spider dress.
And she wanted again something
elemental but he gave her something
that she turned into this incredible
weapon because when she puts it
on she whirls around with this.
It's made out of brass wire
and the wire spin and wobble
and catch the light in
all sorts of directions.
So she became-- she becomes
this kind of avenging,
spinning ball of fiery death.
It's really something.
I don't think he knew.
He almost-- in fact, he says, he
very rarely knew or had a plan
for what she would
do with these things.
And I think what she like is that he
gave her tools that were so simple
that she could do a lot of
different things with them.
So they didn't-- they're not-- they
don't force her into any action.
They don't imply an interpretation.
They don't-- they're not directive,
which is really extraordinary
if you think about it.
He was making set elements
which should be descriptive
and illustrative in nature
but he was giving her things
that were just these little kind
of bundles of the ambiguity.
That then she turned into
whatever she turned them into.
So here, we're just getting a better
look at the specific elements.
So Errand into the Maze, this
quickly followed Cave of the Heart.
This is another journey
into the self.
The maze is again the human heart
and it's a take off on Theseus,
the Minotaur, Ariadne and-- but
really what it is a sort of--
she described it as
a fight against fear
that we all have great
fear inside us.
And in this case, she
triumphs over fear.
But what's-- again, so neat if
you were ask, if I was asked,
I'm a pretty simple minded person.
If I were asked to do Theseus and
the Minotaur thing, of course,
you immediately go-- you
have to do a maze, right?
So how do you do a maze?
And what so need about that is in a
maze there's a really enticing idea.
Like for somebody who thinks about
environmental sculpture and wants
to make spaces and spaces
that human body moves through
and it just seems like tailor-made.
Of course, you are making a maze.
But of course, that's
not what Noguchi did.
He didn't get for a maze
because that's simple,
too simple, too directive again.
So the kind of wishbone thing at the
left ends up being the sort of maze
and it gets a rope kind of wrapped
between it and ends up looking
like knitting needles with knitting
on it and she assembles that
and then disassembles it and breaks
through it in beautiful ways.
And you can see there's a
lot of tethering going on
but the tethering is
all ambiguous as well.
You have this kind of lying mittens
runs off from the base of the line
to which the moon and
the sun are connected,
floating up in the heavens.
Here's the Minotaur-ish figure
with Ariadne and here's the maze
at left with Ariadne performing.
This is not Martha in this case.
But it's-- again, it's
a really good indication
of just how in sync they were.
You know, she was probably
expecting a maze,
a labyrinth of some sort, right?
And she was probably ready to
tell him, I don't want a maze,
you know, it's too simple.
Don't give me a maze.
I'm sure he saw her
coming a mile a way.
So in the post-war years he-- again,
his mind was out questing far away.
This is a wonderful thing that
was never built for reasons
that it will be become
immediately obvious.
This is called Sculpture
to be Seen from Mars.
And it was meant to
be 12 miles long.
And the base of the nose
would have been a mile wide.
And that's funny but sadly that
the basic premise of the piece is
that this is following obviously the
dropping of the two nuclear bombs
or atomic bombs which for Noguchi
was really the end of his optimism.
You know, he was a
technologically utopian.
His best friend was Bucky Fuller.
So he believed that engineering
and technology could
fix everything, right?
Eventually, engineers would
provide free power to everyone
and clean water and all the things
that we all need to survive.
But the dropping of the bombs
for him was really put the
end to that for awhile.
And so this was meant to
be a cenotaph to humanity.
So the idea was that once we
bomb ourselves into extinction
that when some alien race, a million
years from now came towards earth,
which is probably still
radioactive at that point
that they would stop somewhere
nearby like Mars and take a look
at the earth and try to
figure out what happened
and here would be this face that
would say, "Hey, something was here.
At some point something was here."
It's meant to be a kind of a
lasting proof to civilization.
And Noguchi talked to a guy into
New Jersey into making this.
And the guy had already
set aside the land
and they had raised some money
and in the end it fell apart.
But it just gives you a sense
of where Noguchi's mind went
after these projects with Martha.
He spent the next 10 years
almost off and on traveling
around the world, trying to find
a social purpose for sculpture.
That was really important to him.
He didn't want to just make things.
He never wanted to make things.
Maybe this is a good point to
explain the title of the talk,
Sculpting Beyond the Pedestal.
Noguchi had a beautiful phrase
which was that he thought
that we should look beyond what
he called the false horizon
of the Museum Pedestal, which is
a beautiful phrase for the kind
of the insularity of object
making for placement in museums.
That's the last thing
really that he wanted to do.
The only things he wanted to make
for small rooms were useful pieces
of furniture like a coffee table.
So he's looking at things
like this which is--
there's a series of
astronomical observatories
in India called the Jantar Mantar
and they are all instruments,
astronomical instruments.
And this is the one that greatly
influenced the development
of that slide that we saw earlier
and that we'll look at again.
These are basically 18th century
follies built by the governor
of a province in India who had some
very good European instruments,
small one, table top ones.
And he had a theory, which is that
if you take the small instruments
and you make them bigger that
they could be a lot more accurate.
So he built an entire
miniature city of instruments
to measure various
things in the heavens.
It turns out, unfortunately,
that all that happens when you do
that is you magnify all of the
error that's in the instruments.
So, his instruments were atrocious.
They did not yield good
results and he went back
to his tabletop versions and
tried to get better versions.
But they still exist.
You can go visit them and the
best ones remaining are in Delhi
in Jaipur and Noguchi
visited them many times.
And he traveled to Japan for
the first time, in a long time
since 1931 after the war in 19--
first time in 1950 and went
around to all the great sites
of all Japan including
Katsura Imperial Palace.
This is an image, looking
from the old show in palace,
out across what's called
the moon viewing platform.
It is wonderful thing.
It's just a simple bamboo
platform that sits out--
just out from the side of the palace
and it's just an open platform
and that's it and you're just
meant to go out and sit on it.
What I used to-- what I've called--
we probably all called Indian style.
But my daughter now
calls criss-cross,
apple sauce which is cross-legged
and looked up into the sky.
He's also looking inward.
And one of Noguchi's great talents
and this is one that's also related
to dance, is the ability
to flip back
and forth between micro and macro.
So he's thinking galactic,
Sculpture to be Seen from Mars.
This piece is called Mitosis.
So he's also thinking cell division.
And he's flipping back and forth
between cell divisio and galactic,
cell division and galactic.
And somewhere in there is
this space of the theatre.
What so great about the theatre is
that it's a totally
conceptual space.
It is whatever size like
we saw with frontier.
It is whatever size you can manage
to devise away to define it as.
It can be as big as the heavens
or it can be as small as the space
between two people standing
at a fence at a rail fence.
And Noguchi, I think that again,
this work in theatre was
really important component
of feeding his ability to look big
and small at the same time close
and far away at the same time.
This is a great environment and
another one of the Sunken Gardens.
Now we're kind of in the flow.
We're doing kind of a look
at Noguchi's whole career
through these connection
to dance and this a piece
that he made Chase Manhattan
Bank that's still there
and it's made using big river
rocks taken from the Uji River
which is a sacred river in Japan.
Close to Katsura, actually.
And he went and dragged
these rocks out of the river
or bought them from stone sellers.
Got them wherever he could,
ship them back to New York
and built this wavy,
again, this is--
it's a little hard
to see in this angle
but this is a wavy
plaza full of water.
It's a water fountain in the end.
But it is a description
of Einsteinian space.
So you have all of these great
radial crossing lines and every one
of these rocks ends up
being kind of a star system.
It's really-- It's just
a beautiful poetic thing.
So, we're going to look
at kind of a little bit
of where Noguchi ended up.
Again, ambitions, lots of ambition.
This is an early piece of
play equipment called Octetra
and here it is in front
Spoleto Cathedral in Italy.
It's a pretty nice combination.
It's still there not in
front of the cathedral now,
it's in the cathedral
garden but this is--
what's so great about this piece
is that it is-- it's architecture,
it's a structural system
and it's a piece
of monumental sculpture
all at the same time.
It crosses all of those lines and
vibrates and all of those realms.
And Noguchi turned to finally,
this is the only Noguchi playground
that exist in United States.
It's in Piedmont Park
in Atlanta, Georgia.
It's just recently been
renovated for the second time.
It was renovated right
for the Atlanta Olympics
and Herman Miller paid to
renovate it a couple of years ago.
So it's looking terrific again.
There are play cubes.
There's a triple slide.
You can see poking
above the triple side,
a swing kind of a big
lightning bolt thing.
That's a swing in a single plane.
It doesn't have any A-frame to it.
It's just a single plane.
It's just really stunning thing.
And he designed it to teach
kids about centripetal force.
So everyone of the swings
is at different length.
So by swinging on the different
lengths, you learn a lot
about momentum and how
to develop momentum.
The only problem with it is that
the longest of the swings is so long
that you can get going so fast
that you can really hurt somebody.
And so now, Consumer Product Safety
Commission standards preclude swings
of that length.
So they had to remove it.
So there's a gap in it now.
But anyway, that is
also what we end up with
with Noguchi is he gets interested
in making sculpture that's really
about providing the body with
an environment to move within,
you know, just like a stage set
but not something that stage,
something that exist in the real
world and something that, again,
really important value
is not directive.
He really believed in
free-form open play.
He believed in making things that
allow you to come at them a lot
of different ways and use
them a lot of different ways
and that was really unusual
at the time and is part
of why his playgrounds didn't
take off early on and that the--
it's one of the great tragedy
of Noguchi playgrounds is
that he didn't get a
chance to development--
to develop them, excuse me.
So the ideas are sort of
set in amber and, you know,
I wished he'd had 40
years to develop his ideas
and because he really is in
a lot of ways the grandfather
of the playgrounds that we see today
which are so much more imaginative.
At the same time, he is making
work that's bigger and bigger.
And when he does make
sculpture, large scale sculpture,
this is at Storm King in Upstate
New York, if you haven't been.
Wonderful place.
Worth going.
He made the big-- first big site
specific piece for Storm King back
when it was just empty
rolling hills.
It's not at all empty
rolling hills anymore.
It's pack with sculpture.
But they lock the top
of this hill for him
and he placed this piece called
Momo Taro which came out of finding,
a bolder, that he fell in
love with that was so big,
that they couldn't move it
without cutting it in half.
So, it became a piece that was
about a rock that was cut in a half
and then cord out and it kind
of relates to an old folk tale,
Japanese folk tale about
an elderly couple who pray
and pray and pray for a child.
They don't get a child and pray and
pray for a child and eventually,
they get a child that
hatches out of a peach pit.
So this is meant to be
sort of the peach pit.
And what's beautiful about it is
that Noguchi said that forevermore,
one of the conditions of giving
the sculpture, making the sculpture
for Storm King was that people be
able to interact with it physically.
And people do and it's wonderful.
It's really-- It's a neat thing
to go up and curl a lot inside
and become a fetus in the
womb of a Noguchi sculpture.
It's quite a feeling.
This is an amazing thing
in Costa Mesa, California,
if you ever find yourself
in Costa Mesa,
California which I don't recommend,
just kind of generally
but UC Irvine is there.
It's not all bad.
So if you are there,
go through this--
this is in the middle an
industrial park of all things,
a wonderful pretty open-minded
real-estate developer named Henry
Segerstrom in Orange County,
commissioned this from Noguchi.
And basically what it is is a
miniature version of everything
in the state of California.
It's meant to be-- it's meant to
be a condensed one plaza version
of the state of California.
So, every tree in it is a
specimen tree, there are 78--
or 28 different species
of trees in it.
You can see there's a
rushing stream coming
out of the totally conceptual
mountain that's at the right
that kind of that grand
thing that looks
like the Jantar Mantar staircase.
There's a little, miniature desert.
There's a redwood forest that
you have to mount to hill.
Not a big hill but still hill to
get op into because of forest,
redwoods up and the Sierras.
It's really a stunning thing and it
is a complete universe unto itself.
And that's really where Noguchi's
ambitions took him is this idea
of making environments.
But not environments that
are not self-aware and that--
that's one of those
theatrical connection.
So it's California scenario, right?
It's a concept of California.
It's an idea of California.
It's an-- California that is
meant to be like a stage set
and that it ask you to interact
with it or ask you to figure out how
to interact with it, you know, you
can't take the concept out of it.
That's what so neat about it.
And that's a fundamentally
theatrical idea or an idea
that comes out of the management
of the theatrical space.
So this is a piece or combination of
play cubes that are in Piedmont Park
and it put together a little
combination here, you know,
piece of the right permit
collection, Metropolitan Museum
of Art, a different kind of
Kouros at the left, right.
A little boy on a pedestal and which
of these is near to Noguchi's heart?
It's really easy, you know, he
was after the left hand version
that he wanted to make a
base that every little kid
on the planet would want to get
up on top of and be a sculpture,
you know, for a brief
period of time.
And that little boy looking
off into the distance,
this thing is only six feet tall,
this little piece of play equipment
and he's only in Piedmont Park.
But like Martha Graham, he's
looking out into eternity, right?
He is-- well, he really is
a Kouros, you know, he is--
he could be [inaudible], you know,
he's on the [inaudible] of a ship,
he's looking out into the distance.
It's really such a lovely thing
and Noguchi wanted to make pieces
that would inspire that
kind of head space.
I always say about Noguchi when
Noguchi is working really well,
it feels like an airlock just
closed behind you in your mind.
You're transported somewhere
else in this-- a microcosm.
Even with something as simple
these cast concrete cubes
and that really again comes
straight of Martha Graham.
This is at that joint talk I was
talking about open rehearsal.
So this is Lloyd Knight, a
wonderful Martha Graham dancer
on Jocasta's Bed.
He's playing Oedipus and
he's making the point
that he owns her afterwards because
he's come in, he solved the riddle
and Jocasta, his mother is now going
to be his wife and that's going
to be their marriage bed.
He doesn't obviously know anything
but he thinks he knows everything.
So, kind of a dirty secret
of the Noguchi Museum,
I'm contractually obligated to
mention Noguchi's relationship
with Brancusi before ending.
Not really, but it's
kind of like that.
I try not to but in this
case, it's irresistible.
So there's the little sculpture
at the far left of this right next
to the bed is called
Little French Girl.
And the reason I'm showing
her is because she pops
at in Noguchi's studio photography
again and again and again
and here she is standing in
the shadow of Madame Pogany
on a pedestal, her mother, you
know, presumably in this way.
Brancusi in 1927-1928
when Noguchi was
in his studio was making
what he called mobile groups.
And I just want to-- I want to show
this because it's really important
to realize Noguchi is not
the first person to think
about sculpture in
a way that he did.
It came from a lot of
different sources and one
of the most important is Brancusi's
studio which at this point was a--
like a theatre, function
like a theatre.
So Brancusi was constantly arranging
and rearranging the sculptures,
the bases and the furniture and
really unlikely combinations.
So that bases would
become sculptures
and sculptures would become bases
and furniture would be
whatever it wanted to be.
And a piece like Little French Girl
really became an animated figure
running around through the studio,
finding herself in
different scenarios.
Here's another-- she's standing
right in the midst of what looks
like kind of rubble but actually
this is a Brancusi studio
at its happiest with all of
these sculptures spread around in
and amongst raw materials and then
finally she gets her start turn.
So here she is standing next
to an endless column looking
up at a piece called cup, which is
just carved out of wood on the top
of what is acting like a
kind of so [inaudible].
But I have a two-year-old and he
spends all of his time like this,
you know, just looking up
at surfaces that he wants
to pull things down off of.
So this is a great-- you know,
there's a lot of DNA in here
for the Noguchi that I've tried
to present to you tonight.
And so I'm just going to leave you
with another image
of a slide mantra.
This is the white Slide Mantra that
was made to be the center piece
of Noguchi's Venice
Biennale exhibition.
He represented the US in
1986 and he put at the center
of the American Pavillion, a
slide and a usable slide at that
which at the time was really
something and there was a rumor
that he was going to win
the Golden Lion Award.
He was 82.
He had an amazing career.
The show was called
"What is Sculpture?"
He'd really earn the right to
ask that question again and again
and again by this point
in his career.
But because he included Akari
lamps, which were considered
and this is going to sound hilarious
a crafts commercialization of art.
You know, now art is nothing
but crafts commercialization.
That's-- Venice Biennale
is sort of, you know,
less elegant than a
Mercedes Showroom.
But anyway at the time, he did two
things, he presented the lanterns
and then he had a working
slide at the center of his show
and that just was too much for
European art critics especially.
But there's a wonderful story
that I want to leave you with.
He's standing in the Pavilion.
This is in Bayfront Park in
Miami, where the piece is now.
Visit it if you're ever there.
It's another failed
park projects, sadly.
And this is just the remains of it.
But so he's standing there with
Issey Miyake who's a friend
of his, the fashion designer.
And Miyake they were
watching kids just cycle
down the slide again
and again and again.
He said, "Isn't it
weird to have kids all--
running all over you sculptures?
That must be strange.
You know, that's-- you don't
make sculpture for that?
And Noguchi said, "No, that's
exactly what I make sculpture for.
What I think about them sliding
on my sculpture is I think
they're going to learn a lot
about sculpture with their butts."
And where I started,
the great fortune
of having the Martha Graham Company
used Noguchi's sculpture everyday,
every year.
They still have 14 or so
out of the 19 or so dances
that he made such for in repertoire.
They breathe life and
soul and purpose
into those things every
time they touch them.
And that's exactly
what Noguchi wanted.
I think it would probably
be among the proudest facts.
And, you know, they ran in lock step
so much their entire careers I
would think of them as like the Adam
and the Eve of the
American modernism
and of the pluralistic version
of it that we all believe in.
They-- Sort of at the very end of
his life there's a wonderful moment,
when the museum opened he was famous
for not showing up
to his own openings.
In fact, he made a cutout
version of himself as a void
so it was not himself as a figure,
it was himself a void
cutout of a piece of wood.
So he was absence as presence and
he gave that to his dealer and said,
"I'm not coming, but
you can use this."
So he-- it was an hour and a half
into the opening of the museum
and he hadn't showed up and
there was one very simple reason
because when he finally did enter
about two hours into the opening,
he entered in arm-in-arm with
Martha and she had been late
and he wasn't going to walk into
his own museum until she showed
up because he knew what an
important moment it was.
He knew how symbolic it would be
and he knew what they had meant
to each other and he knew what
they meant to the 20th century,
especially in American art making.
And that's really the best picture
I think I can leave with you
with in terms of understanding.
Their importance to each other
and her importance to him in terms
of developing the way he thought
about what sculpture should be.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
I think we're supposed
to take some questions
if anyone has anything
would like to please?
>> David Pylar: Would you
mind just waiting for the mic.
>> Dakin Hart: Oh sorry.
I think we have a microphone.
>> Thank you.
Thank you so much that was great.
Question, are there any mockups,
copies or originals of the sets
in the museum, Martha Graham sets?
>> Dakin Hart: Yeah.
It's something that I
think about all the time.
We have bits and pieces
and it's terrible actually.
It makes very, very
hard to show them.
We have a couple of
original things, we have--
they made some casts of
great pieces like the chair,
the great chair from
Appalachian Spring.
They together again in their '80s,
they were both thinking about legacy
and how they were going
to keep their museum
and companies going respectively.
So they chose a few great iconic
settlements and they cast them
in bronze and then they
each took half and sold them
to help raise money to support
the museum and the company.
And so we have a couple of those
but what we really would like to do
and we're talking with Graham
about doing this and we're looking
for joint funding is to reengineer
all the sets for the 21st century
because every time Martha
Graham travels to Europe,
it cost him about $40,000
to get the sets their
and $40,000 to get them back.
They take up a huge container
and they're very, very heavy.
And they're so heavy
that they're not--
they hurt them selves because
just moving them around back--
the bigger something is
and the heavier it is,
the more danger it is to itself.
So we're really interested
in working together
with a great industrial
designer to redesign them
in some new material whether it's
carbon fiber or aluminum and use
that principle of flat packability,
so that they can be broken down
and maybe be able to
ship the whole thing
in like one-tenth the
weight and half the volume.
And we-- I'd love to have
a set for the museum, too,
so that we have something
to exhibit.
But it's-- he wasn't
precious about them.
So we don't have a single one of
the original models for these sets.
We have photographs,
but none of the models
which I would dearly love to have.
Maybe they're out there somewhere.
There are a lot of
important lost Noguchis.
So keep your eye open
at flea markets.
And if you see something that
looks like that little chair,
it might be that little chair.
>> I just want to know if there's
going to be another opportunity
like in New York to interact
with three or four of these sets,
because I'll go there
if there is, you know.
>> Dakin Hart: Yeah.
I know it was really
an amazing event.
In that picture I showed of Lloyd,
they did their open rehearsal
and then the audience
flooded that stage
and you could go do
exactly what he was doing
which is walk down the bed.
I think they're going to
do more and more of that.
That was a Kickstarter campaign.
Do you all know Kickstarter?
>> Yeah.
>> Dakin Hart: You know a
way to raise money online.
>> So if you donated so much
money you got to go this thing.
>> Dakin Hart: Yeah, it
wasn't even very much money.
They are really trying to open
up and be more interactive and,
you know, I don't know how much
you all know about the history
of the Graham company, but
it was on its last legs.
I mean it was really went
through an incredibly tough period
and LaRue Allen and Janet
Eilber deserve so much credit
because they really have brought
it back, breathe new life into it.
And they're trying to do exactly
what we're trying to do which is
to make the vision of a
really unique person live
on in a meaningful way.
You know, we're not
trying to run sort
of [inaudible] graphic
organizations.
It's not-- The museum is
not a Mosque or a Mausoleum.
You know, we really want it to live
and be contemporary and current.
And that's what Graham is
doing with his program.
That's what they're doing with the
help of the Library of Congress
by commissioning new work.
They're doing a lot more
work with new choreographers,
contemporary choreographers.
There are so many parallels.
It's really, really interesting.
But I imagine they'll
do a lot more of it,
because it was a huge success.
>> Thank you.
>> Dakin Hart: Sure.
>> So I just want to give a plug for
your museum which I think is great
and it's very easy to get
to if you're in Manhattan.
It's just across the river and
great article about it last Friday,
I think it was in the
New York Times.
But I have a question about
the Herman, are there any notes
that he had written
about his ideas for that?
>> Dakin Hart: It's a one
throwaway line in his autobiography.
>> Uh huh.
>> Dakin Hart: And scholar named
Robert Tracy did a little bit
of work on it, trying to nail
it down and he did find a couple
of details, but there's
basically nothing.
>> Because obviously there's a lot
of interactive art
installations now that--
I mean, he was the
precursor of all that.
>> Dakin Hart: Yeah, [inaudible]--
>> Yeah, oh absolutely.
>> Dakin Hart: You know, if any
of those projects had been made--
>> Yeah.
>> Dakin Hart: You know, Michael
Heizer is busy in the desert trying
to make the city a
Mayan City basically.
>> So, on the material side
the stone and his wood,
did he ever do anything in glass?
>> Dakin Hart: Oh yeah.
>> OK.
>> Dakin Hart: He did.
He tried-- He used everything.
You know, he also worked awhile
with plastic until he just--
at the end he's busy and he said,
"He couldn't find the
spirit plastic."
You just never-- but there probably
are plastics now that he would.
You know, I think he'd
be all over carbon fiber,
he would be making
computer-based work, you know, he--
again, he never met new
technology that he didn't like.
>> Do you have any?
Because I don't recall
any glass pieces
at the museum, do you have any?
>> Dakin Hart: Well, he
made a thing for Steuben.
Steuben commission
contemporary artist to make work
and he did a piece,
it's not a great thing.
But yes he did-- trying to think.
I mean, it related to a series of
lamps that he proposed in the '40s
that were lamps made to order,
they were in plastic and glass.
But they-- in the end
they just didn't catch on.
And the Luminaire was
the manufacturer.
But we just don't know.
Really none exists.
So maybe none were bought
or maybe a few were bought
and they just disappear
and-- you know, or broken,
ended up in flea markets and another
thing to keep an eye out for.
>> OK.
>> I wanted to ask you about
the dance step was the maze?
>> Dakin Hart: Errand into the Maze.
And you mentioned that Martha
Graham worked with fear
and I just wanted what you knew
about her working with the sculptor
on the fear and how they
collaborated, around in emotion?
>> Dakin Hart: What's really
interesting in 1946 coming--
he made the anteversion
of Appalachian Spring.
You know, you have that--
we have that wonderful Shaker house
basically in fence and, you know,
it's so filled with optimism
and that frontier spirit.
He made it work with Ruth
Page in 1946 called the Bells.
And in the Bells, there's a Shaker
church which is just a raw frame,
but huge very, very tall like 20
feet tall white painted frame.
It's all hinged.
So it gets lifted up in a place
and it looks like it's solid.
But it has hinges spread
throughout asymmetrically.
So when it's lower
the rail is lowered
from the ceiling, the
church collapses.
And the theory of this
dance or the program
of the dance is basically
that Hitler wins.
And it is a figure that's
kind of a demonic figure
and it's almost exactly
the same basic premise
because you have a
bride-groom and a bride.
And in this case rather than raise
a house and get married and go off
into this great future
life in America, they are--
the bride-groom was killed
and the specter figure
carries the bride away.
So that's the difference between
1944 and 1946 because even
from Noguchi even thought we had
won the war he was so shattered
by the way that we won the war.
And by the-- just the effect,
the impact that it had overall.
So it's something that he's basic--
I think he really never
recovered from that in a way.
You know, the space program like for
so many Americans became the
redemption of technology.
Yeah, the retraining of all of that
technology and all that brain power
that had been put into
weaponry and putting it off
to something better
and that helped a lot.
But he had lost that sort
of fundamental optimism.
I don't know as much about Graham.
She was always harder.
She was tougher in every way.
I don't think she was not the
starry-eyed optimist that he was.
So I don't think she went through
the same sort of disillusionment,
plus she was so much
more-- he was an introvert.
But she was really-- you know,
she was a scientist of the soul.
You know, she really that just-- and
that didn't changed really at all.
Even her source material
didn't change very much
where it did for him a lot more.
I don't know.
That's not a very good answer.
That'd be a really good
questioned to ask Janet.
>> I was wondering if you could
elaborate on the Ruth Page,
what you started with, but
then go back to the '20s
and more Martha was first
and then how did that dynamic
with the three of them evolve?
>> Dakin Hart: Well,
I think, after--
Noguchi stayed friends
with Ruth and then would go
on to do this other performance
with Ruth and the aluminum sculpture
that I showed you Ruth and
her husband, so Noguchi meet
up with her husband
after the affair.
They had a one year affair.
And he tried to get her to
leave her husband and marry him.
Ruth was an amazing person, too.
So Ruth left her honeymoon.
She was honeymooning in Monte
Carlo, she got the opportunity
to go audition for Diaghilev
in the Russian ballet,
which was just nearby down
on the coast and at the time.
And so she left her new husband.
No. Well not.
They were on their honeymoon.
But they were only few
days into their honeymoon
and she sent him back to
Chicago and she stayed
and started and actually made it.
She was the only American
ever employed by the Diaghilev
and she went out on tour.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
She's right in between.
She was a little bit
older than Noguchi.
She's an amazing figure and the
Chicago Historic-- it's renamed.
The Chicago History Museum has
now digitized a lot of video
of her dances and they're
worth going to see.
She made a really amazing
dance in 19, like,
26 called the flapper
and the quarterback.
So she really-- She
pioneered Americana.
Amazing, amazing person.
Again, she really isn't
very well-known just
because she worked in Chicago.
If she had moved to
New York and work
to New York she would have been
every bit Martha's equal, you know,
different obviously but--
>> Ellen Landau has
written a couple of articles
about Martha Graham's
influence on Noguchi.
I don't know if you're familiar
with them or if you could comment
on her influence on how
Noguchi presented his art.
She's talking specifically
about murals in Mexico.
>> Dakin Hart: Yeah, I
mean so Noguchi did--
this was another one of
those Noguchi had a thing
with Frida Kahlo.
He was very friendly
with Diego Rivera.
Rivera invited him down to Mexico
to do a mural in a public market
and there are a lot of American
artist who went down to do projects.
These were people who are
involved with the WPA mostly or--
but they were kind of sidelined
WPA people like Noguchi
and Diego Rivera offered
this amazing opportunity.
So Noguchi went down.
It's still there.
It's been restored.
It's in pretty good shape now.
And it is pure social realism.
It's very like-- the
figures are really
like what you saw in
the press panel.
But it includes a lot of interesting
little things and actually one
of the greatest piece of Noguchi a
[inaudible] came of that experience
because he wanted to include some
scientific notation in the mural.
And so he decided he was going
to include E equals mc squared.
But he realized that he had no idea
what it meant even though he had
read his book the Arthur
Eddington book.
And so he sends Bucky a
telegram for Mexico City
to New York City saying can you
explain in not too many words
because he's paying for
the return telegram.
Can you explain E equals mc squared?
And it is one of the funniest
things ever written really
because it's Bucky who is
notorious blowhard and very hard
to understand, but always, you
know, wonderful to listen to trying
to condense that down in
explaining E equals mc squared
in a very compressed format.
And what's so funny is with the
punctuations of stop, stop, stop,
stop, stop really all
you wanted to do is stop
because it just gets worst and worst
and worst, it's so funny to think
of Noguchi receiving
these telegram, you know,
and trying to make head-tails of it
and then he was, oh right, you know,
I got exactly what I asked for.
But the Mexico City [inaudible] was
usually important because it's one
of this formative-- Noguchi is
so much more socially connected
and socially sophisticated and
interested than people realize.
Like his interment World War II
which is a hugely important story
and we're coming up on the 75th
anniversary of Executive Order 9066.
We'll be doing a little show and
I know a lot of people are going
to be doing shows about
interment one way or the other.
But Noguchi is self-interned, you
know, he chose to go into a camp
because he believes so much in this
country that he was willing to take
on the responsibility of one of
the worst mistakes we've ever made
and personally try to
help make it better,
because the war department led
him to believe that if you went
into the camp, Poston,
which was the biggest camp
that they would help him
in redesigning it making it more
humane starting arts programs.
We have a blueprint for
his redesigned of the camp,
which was basically kind of
turning it into Paris and, you know,
or as much as close as you could get
to Paris in the desert, in Poston,
Arizona where it was
like 120 everyday.
And-- But it was so horrible
and they had lied to him.
So he wasn't able to do anything.
And he was-- it turns out
he was totally out of sync
with the job he's interned there
who we had nothing in common with.
It was a nightmare for him and he
tried to get out after two months.
But once they had him
they wouldn't let him go.
And it took months
in the end for him
to win his release even hough
he wasn't subject to interment
because he was a resident
of New York.
Not a resident of the West Coast.
>> David Plylar: I think we have
time for one more if anybody.
>> Thanks.
When you were talking about
the high school he attended
in Indiana [inaudible] understood
that school had been
founded by the industrialist.
And so there was a great focus
on getting the children to work
with their hands and invent things.
Was-- Did Noguchi begin
to work sculpturally
or spatially at that age?
I had read that he-- when he
was in med school at Columbia
that he took a night
course in sculpture
and that's where the flame was lit.
But was it earlier?
>> Dakin Hart: It was
much earlier than that.
Yeah. And it's really all
down to his mother who was one
of these figure like
Martha, you know,
is a person with just absolute will.
His mother was a Bryn Mawr
girl, Irish-American stock
and she was not married
to his father
who is a famous Japanese poet,
but was editor, [inaudible] an ad
in the paper, New York,
she's from Brooklyn
and she followed his father,
Noguchi is born in Los Angeles
and followed his father to
Japan, she spoke no Japanese,
she had no job but she
decided that Noguchi
who at the time was Sam Gilmore
because he actually was unnamed.
They just called him Boy
for the first three years
because his father wanted
to name him, you know,
that was the father's
right to name the son.
So they just call him-- well, they
had a bunch of different names.
They call them Yo, which is
short for Yonejiro, his father's.
But-- So he went Boy-- Yo and Boy.
And so he finally got named
when she took him to Japan.
But in the meantime his father
had started a Japanese family.
So they couldn't even stay with him.
That was very awkward
and Noguchi spend--
but Noguchi went to
elementary school in japan.
But his mother they built their own
house and his mother plan the house.
Noguchi is about eight at the time.
And Noguchi apprenticed to the
carpenter who is building the house
and learn to do basic planing and
sort of simple task that he could do
as well as some decoration
and he made some decorative
panels for the house.
And he also did this
for his garden then.
It really his first major work
was the garden around their house.
And his mother gave
him that responsibility
and said she wanted to
him to do the garden.
And it's a wonderful story
because it had a water feature.
But for the water feature he
needed a really good rock.
And everyday he walked
across the neighbor's land
and on the neighbor's land
there was a beautiful rock.
And so he tells the story.
It's just a lovely story.
So he stole the rock and made
it a part of his water feature.
And he said that as long as they
were in that house everyday,
he feared that the neighbor would
come over and recognize the rock.
Now Noguchi even at eight was
a sort of person who thought
that people recognize specific rocks
because he recognized
specific rocks.
He recognized the quality
of this rock.
And so from his point of view he
had stolen this neighbor's greatest
treasure to make the center piece
of his garden and he would continue
to do that as we saw with the
Chase Manhattan sunken garden.
He bought all that rock
before he had the job.
And then he used it as leverage to
guilt his friend, the architect,
into making sure that he got the
job, because he's already taken all
of this rock out of Uji
River to do the commission.
So he was thinking about
it for a long time.
And the school only, you know, it
only increased and the clock case
that I mentioned called
"Measured Time" was a commission
from that man, Ed Grimley who
was his first great mentor
and really supported him.
Noguchi was a genius for
biting the hand that fed him.
He designed this case for
Grimley and it was a big success
but it was a high price point
because it's a very
sophisticated shape in Bakelite.
It was expensive to make and
Grimley said, "This is so great,
we're making tens of thousands.
They're selling.
We want to do a cheaper version."
Grimley's vision was this was the
very first timer clock for the home.
So for timing your Turkey it
had a 2 hour timer, wind timer,
and it was based on timer
clocks from industry, you know,
clocking clockout clocks which
were very, very accurate,
they were the most accurate ones
going, so he repackaged one of those
for he home to go on every
stove in America, again,
[inaudible] thinking, efficiency and
improving the home and all of that.
So Noguchi designed this
case, so Grimley asked him,
"Can you design another one
that's less expensive to produce?"
And then there's like all this
humming and hanging, you know,
weather, like maybe kind
of possibly square-ish.
And Noguchi wrote back to
him and said not only no,
but hell no anybody
could make you a box.
I won't do it.
Maybe if you let me go back to the
original one I can make it better
because Grimley had n
to let him model it.
He'd had to draw it and then
it was produced from drawings.
But he really wanted
to hand model it.
So he offered to improve it, which
surely would've made it like two
or three times as expensive.
Sorry that was another
long digression
but Noguchi is full great stories.
Thank you again.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.